we begin this morning with rising
tensions with North Korea and Venezuela
last night in a telephone conversation
President Trump and Chinese President Xi
Jinping said they are both committed to
denuclearizing the north the Korean
Peninsula but as mr. Trump leaves the
door open for a diplomatic solution in
Asia he's not ruling out military action
in South America he declined to talk by
phone with Venezuela as president until
democracy is restored there the
president is also continuing his
vacation at his Golf Resort in New
Jersey that's where we find Errol
Barnett traveling with the president
Errol good morning good morning as
tensions escalate between the United
States and North Korea president Trump
has been making himself more available
to questions from the media since
arriving in Bedminster last week he's
taken reporters questions on five
separate occasions voicing only harsh
language for one of the world's most
unpredictable threats if anything
happens to Guam there's going to be big
big trouble in North Korea president
Trump's repeated warnings to kim
jeong-hoon have defined his
administration's messaging for the past
few days and his twitter feed friday
morning he noted the u.s. is locked and
loaded
when asked if Germany would stand by the
u.s. in case of an attack Chancellor
Angela Merkel said she didn't see a
military solution president Trump said
Merkel does not speak for the US and
refused to accept criticism his language
goes too far my critics are only saying
that because it's me if somebody else
under the exact same words that I did
say what a great state despite the
heated rhetoric the AP reports of
ongoing back channel communications
between Pyongyang and Washington
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson and US
ambassador to the UN nikki Haley met
with the president in Bedminster
yesterday as they try to reassure allies
that diplomacy is the first option I
think what the press is doing
trying to support our efforts by
ensuring North Korea understands what
the stakes are
the US has been in a state of readiness
in the Northern Pacific for years
with 28,000 American troops stationed in
South Korea and 3,000 more expected in
the coming days the governor of Guam
posted this video to Facebook Friday
evening showing President Trump
reassuring him that Americans there will
be safe I'm glad to hear you're holding
the helm sir late Friday president Trump
also spoke with Chinese President Xi
Jinping who of course is keen to avoid
nuclear war in neighboring North Korea
and according to chinese state media
president xi urged both sides to use
restraint and quote avoid remarks that
could escalate tensions Dana
Errol Barnett thank you